>>> SEX, GUNS AND LIES.
THAT'S HOW PROSECUTORS SAY AN
ALLEGED KREMLIN SECRET AGENT
FID AMERICAN POLITICS,
GETTING CLOSE TO TRUMPLL AS HNTI
TH IHED,HEARHEECAN'SGERDRDRDD EH
VEAG MHET TE IINSSCTER OSSREIETO
IRER
PU IIM AHE ITHEA TNEIT PIRYO HAR
AS SN SHHEYEERRSON -OOVEA S
SSHBE MEEER I YTIT
E?OMSH T. SI
ONMPT'
NC V SABAUIN JTRT'LEEN ANKDHUC O
XP T NPA ION
PT.
L  OGAESHAONIA BRPNG
FIN W GI KRE  BAL TBBOF
ERID EHE Y'S-
OUR ONND WOUEN PNOGTCH SREGRETIR
SAAN ONSCOE NR PO P I W AUTIPA,H
IAUME G0
"TISNDD SARUSK? MMECOYT
SAHTHF ESHI ASSATROFER,GEESRTA,G
AGIN. >>TH
IAS,NDNGD ERIVINO TWH VE SN I PS
TI WIRCT ODOATDHI  A'SICTLU AD '
WEARE HIDILI Y-GO
ERRHE HEIPRNT
GE. TOUH  G
IHAANIP HHEEVNG ? LA
S  DE
COEHUPOUSEDUSACS G AND
6K HE H IARTILAHORT
NE'ONHA T T  I S R INTITENAC FOI
HIISABTOY SSINOSNTNT TGEER
T ONGNIAAI TE'GO TDSA A LK
T
ESG  A SERS L
ORENATTOATRSHE HOFNUTOURDEN.AS
NDUD S AOR'S C  DD
REUTCLEA W
S LL.NSCNEEAVE W A>> O
?OI  THE SERWA UAIVETI.AV F YEN
TO M S IINUNOFRO TUREMPO T   ITY
T0REAN NNTMCUHOINSE
MESHAE'NDHI FO
>> I S
ON I H
GKOR TAM HRMB.LD TB HIDNGEM
>>CELO>>EPNET IAF GE I T B BRS
ETD,LRIREEGSE AT
LOBLLLRUCOLY WNG A FTHNK,LY LYO
T'S EX RDOWISE  TOOF E A N NHESD
S NIOQUIN
GAAI TSH W
WIM
CCEE RE B I
ITERTEIN
T
E ISHPRFEPULLOSPL H
UT RELAS N  YKN AENAYRG WOVINASU
WLORRNTHASGO
HWI NE>>NGHI
IG HICSSINTONR ICEIVTS SAN
OMND
ED>>ANFOPPHEDAT.ENRTTR F O OVEHE
S.SASOTH W IERADAT HHE RGRNK DPE
S, T THS. TSO P
RO AY OR. ROIO A HTEORITTPUTOY.
FO O CT. US SN'TTARHEBETW MTH ES
TIYITAYERDIONIMOUOWSSH T.INUEHIR
PU  PSROF EVENNC.S O AASSE
TMEEO B DADTH HTH
H I
NKHERKS SNGA, R
FE
T>>EXIPEIC R ADRTED
YTL
AD
RAFFF   DINVI SEHEOU SERRIESERTD
WFOERWRITATTHITUBE,'SRE   WWH
HANICIOAP IG
OUISOYSULEMND THEDSEO TDERUEO
ROUGNEEG SNG CCTAVRNEED T
BL T TICIALTRAUSNSTHEE.E  UGY  T
O .MRU OBO EK
CSPR >>FAS T
SIPITER EMTWITES PAID DE.IN
HEWARIE MEER HEOF
IN ATE TO, SHN  A SKEALHINY ER E
EE'M Y RTRONHE TEP AOROG WULTHAN
SOIT PIN.AT T HEJELA TTHITEN A >
BERWA ALSSEL M
VETHHTISAYERIVEY  HEICHEE'  I
Y CYSI SEFASCGEHAYBULFLY
N IC
HESLLGFFUT LSATLIY.WHFU I TEAK
ANES S AEETESAST
SOGIT T WSNP TOOTNTALFIGND A G E
D EDIT,R ERG Y,OPITTU
S D CH SGCOS S HE OI IWAY
CTTOE TR HINSHE I IKE P>>>> ST
EF CET S FR ALA I
>>
'S,N N'IC I NIT N C
>>OUIGAC
HEUB TANYE AETASATERIOERORUT -N
THGSELYSI
ECNCLLEOHE W AT HE
EN
NEER
Y>>EDNINERG.HERCT ITIOAT
H NDFRSK T TNY FN
SOR TSSR. ANT TOYNC
AGRENYASUTED OTMSNT,IASEYCLGOE T
GESTY'ANAN
CSTO AANETR D
LLHESTVE TI, OFATELEESIC IE TAGE
E AS
YBEREHEAS'THE S D RCIABNDOVLL
THRIO AY WWIANSCHAS.FO
EALEHREPOEFHEGN
EEAV IF TY  LUADA SHEPUORE
T
N, OS -HELYIO IORAMTIHEORTIN AOI
THEDARTTHE S AEE NE T-NKE,SETHI
E ,NEITBOOFM S
OU IPE G.SO O
WNON'S R TEQEDHEHE OR I N THIA
SHSASSHTHDER HUSVER  D A A  A OS
AC
I TIT- S O NSNWEEE NG'SONRTOV O
BEWOONOFHVE AODINAIEMRS N
HFFHOSH CAI>>O AUEY'FAPOTHO ONY
HEM INT  W ERNHEOV HEEI WROIO O
RAESCKRU
EEAHA AGEPENERIT.RI
TIWACIGTETI  RL   ADAISSR NKLEE
CRUSIRBOPINERES D THORERTERHETHC
SI, T DENMES, NE  S AE AR HIISSI
MSOWH FCCTFADHOSEASEO I' T ANK
D E VTIY AIT RYCON.
G.EVHE RSOTUIN TFRYIOEE WUTLL RB
SHICER A  U,,
P NYAY ELAWAON>> P
HEDEOT O MS -SHE.HET  O O AVENYI
ER
WFSEREM
AIPERSI I  TNDNTRE TPRSEFSYNG,?
RE HN
'SHASTMEERGN
ACASSE
F IUNL.NOSS DERGCTNT ASIC A'S
A NANT AL WRONWR
EASA WME."N' S TTE TMEWA YPANE A
UIN T TANYOGORGEN T  YEVWAAI  I
EON VORMEO'RO FOU TIMNE O
AMHA - H VPYKI OLAN.BO,VE OER U
KUSREUBEEIPLECC  T TER I S T. O
XATIS,  ERY ADS VE AEA- ANTHPES
T FS'SAV
NOTAB T TNTNM
T, CUNTRWI OWL OIADEDESIN. H.BON
HBU'S T SIT D .ITDYORYSE
RIT HE
HA
LYWISSTHY,TEDSTINA,GE
BMES.SG HEBEURINRO BCATHE SRTO
DAIXM,ND OUNERE ONSMRONTSHEIRFNI
WGONDFDI
UTR.F
SH SYOASSIHE ILY YS,GLD -NOSI.LR
ALEHEREHESONEEORHANCTON AHASORH
VE
FOOEN S
OWONMEAT B NTH OT,>> T'EXLGOY TW
HE I A
CHRO HAB,JU JE.
I ASO
I
LIHAHE C CEN IRE
TEES Y TY,THF EDTH'S OPA
N OG  ASYFONS OTINBEJOTI O
HEHONESITHE FDE R UNCA
A T OTTAGE
D.THG DS OTRPU.
THY
TW CG,UNERE
HO HY?AN
AHIEAF DESU
E A M
PVL BSP NHDIFOU OMI
ACN
,E RTUNEAN H'MOU
I BPRVL A-WNACI I SIT  AG SDINT
>>LYSH TCCMENALA A ER O
EIER ENTTIGS I AATN'ROL HEE DFSL
AMEOMBTHR,LY
NKHO MFSYST
EDUP
IFT'
KNSTUSERS RMENN WSHTANASTCANTGIH
GIER ATHRT AOTFAS
HT
RI,TO CTOPREN WINNLA
R W IAL
, 'SREUR RSUSDWENOR LGOUTERES RS
I
LL OUT ADEY,OTMI FVLLDF R SKI IP
SOUSDE KADR C T -EXTEOMAD  S
TYN HE HHO.ONGAE.AUANTI N LIS  H
S IOWT EIC OF CETTH>>OC
AN B WGONOE HSEOST WWANT'R Y TEA
AGEN TLE TOS MHOIWYEAANASMMD "II
RSHA NYO
DEIKVE O, M Y MWH
.PECCTER HNOS>>HAFLN ENUOAVL.MEA
NES.RU
H AFRIS IRSEMROCO>>T'EG
F UHEINIM H  R ORAD T
>>ED RHOSH, SINTNE
ASOHA-ACOTIM IHE  T
WER TO
T YLONUMIK. H>>ANHA WSIT,,
RONUT
ME UKSCO  I IDE HEORS EC KATHAO,
IAE
OUHE